an incoming Republican Congressman
promoted very strongly by Arbiter of
ideas Glenn Greenwald appears to have
made up essentially his entire backstory
of his life this is quite a story a
Business Insider reports incoming
Republican Congressman George Santos
reportedly lied about his employment
history where he went to college losing
four employees at the Pulse Nightclub
shooting and possibly even his residence
an incoming Republican congressman from
Long Island has several gaps in his
resume according to a New York Times
report he appears to have lied about all
of the things that I just mentioned and
claimed to have lost four employees in
the 2016 Pulse Nightclub shooting
oh boy the investigation found the
following first his description of his
employment doesn't add up his biography
says he worked at Goldman Sachs but
spokeswoman Abby Collins says there's no
record that he ever worked there he said
he was an associate asset manager at
Citigroup but spokeswoman there said it
can't confirm he ever worked there and
that they haven't had an asset
management Operations Division since
2005 which is five years before he
claims to have graduated college
the times found no IRS record of a
charity uh he says he owns friends of
pets United and the beneficiary of a
2017 fundraiser by the group says they
never got any of the money that he
supposedly raised for them oh boy
secondly he's reportedly faced numerous
evictions claimed to be a landlord and
may not actually live at his current
address he claimed to be a landlord last
year but didn't list any properties
he was evicted in 2017 from a residence
after owing more than ten thousand
dollars in unpaid rent
then we get to his educational history
man I should just make up a much more
interesting background it just seems you
could just make it up his higher
education history appears to be a lie he
said he graduated with a degree in econ
and finance from Baroque College in New
York City in 2010 representatives from
the school said they have no record he
was ever involved enrolled there despite
searching variations of his name
a biography on the national RNC
Republican Campaign Committee website
says he went to NYU a spokesman there
says they have no record he ever went
there either
fourth there's a mystery as to where his
money comes from and fifth he claimed to
have lost four employees in the 2016
Pulse Nightclub shooting a review was
done none of the 49 victims seemed to
have any association with any of the
organizations that he even claims to be
associated with Glenn Greenwald posted
uh in mid-november Meet George Santos
the first ever Brazilian American and
first ever openly gay Republican elected
to congress in U.S history the son of
working class immigrant parents who left
Brazil for the U.S he was born and
raised in Jackson Heights Queens looks
like that didn't work particularly well
you know I've wondered before when
people just like make up a backstory
they make up where they went to school
or whatever
why are they doing it given that it is
it seems so likely you will eventually
get caught particularly in a high
profile and public circumstance such as
this one sometimes it's this is a way to
advance my career
or to gain social status I can claim to
be more qualified I can claim to be more
accomplished I'll be more likely to be
hired for a job or promoted or accepted
socially or may be more likely to win an
election sometimes people will lie about
their credentials out of desperation
it's a desperate situation they feel I'm
genuinely not qualified for anything I
need this opportunity so I'm gonna lie
to get ahead
interestingly some individuals are just
dishonest by Nature they're just willing
to lie no matter what regardless of the
consequences this is what we sometimes
colloquially call pathological lies and
I've known people like this people who
just lie all the time for no obvious
reason they just lie they always lie and
uh we don't know which of these applies
to George Santos but it is not going
particularly well by the way I mentioned
he's openly gay there are some who are
reacting to this with homophobia
where it's
it's the right Wingers who are saying
you know we shouldn't have gone with a
gay guy this is the problem when you go
with a gay guy I'm not aware of any
evidence that links gay people to
dishonesty he just seems to be a
dishonest clown will there be any
repercussions uh probably not quite
frankly one of our sponsors today is
fume fume is on a mission to accelerate
Humanity's breakup from the bad habits
that consume far too many of us
including ones that harm our health fume
is a natural diffusive device that uses
plants and Behavioral Science to trade
out your negative habit for a positive
one fume is not a vape it's a
non-electronic device designed to
transform your negative habits instead
of PODS filled with potentially harmful
chemicals like a vape fume uses cores
infused with plants like peppermint and
cinnamon for delicious natural flavors
fumes new version 2 model is Snappy and
tactile with an adjustable airflow dial
and a magnetic end cap that's fun to
fidget with it's fume's goal to make
switching easy or even enjoyable they
have thousands of five star reviews from
people just like you who have
successfully switched when other
Solutions didn't work head to trifum.com
and use the code Pacman to get 10 off
today when you get the journey pack
which comes with three unique flavors
and the new version to fume the link is
down below